Nous sommes là ici au cœur du tumulus Saint Michel à Carnac
Dpnc là, on est en train de visiter à travers des...
des couloirs, des tunnels, qui ont été creusés au début du 20e siècle
des tunnels pour accéder à la tombe centrale qui contenait tout ce mobilier
des haches en jade alpin, des perles et pendeloques en variscite ou en turquoise,
et un peu de céramique.
"Et parmi ces éléments de parure, il y avait de la, de la...des perles en callaïs
donc des minéraux verts. Cette présence de minéraux verts, de parures en
matière minérale verte avait intrigué non seulement les archéologues mais également les minéralogistes."
"Donc sur le dallage
principal, ici, vous aviez
l'anneau qui était à peu près central
avec la hache en jade qui partait comme ça;  à son extrémité au niveau du tranchant les deux grosses pendeloques,
puis une autre pendeloque, puis une autre hache en jade."   "Donc il y a eu un tout un
questionnement sur l'origine de ces... la provenance de ces matériaux et dans les années
la découverte d'une... d'une mine
à côté de Nantes, à Pannecé
de variscite,  puisqu'en fait on a découvert que c'était de la variscite, qui est un phosphate d'aluminium comme de la turquoise
et donc on s'est dit, bien, c'est juste à côté et les les pierres viennent de quelques dizaines au plus
cent et quelques kilomètres.
Et après dans les années.. un petit peu plus tard ,70-80 les mines de Can Tintorer à
côté de Barcelone ont été découvertes et fouillées et on a on s'est aperçu que c'étaient des mines de variscite qui dataient du néolithique
Gavà,  c'est aussi (une) mine on a travaillé au sous-sol de Gavà pour obtenir la variscite mais aussi c'est un atelier
A Gavà, on  travaillait aussi la variscite pour lavoir des pièces de collier avec différentes formes avec différentes morphologies
il y a des pièces de collier en forme de disque
il y a des pièces de collier en forme de petit tonneau, il y a des plaquettes, des formes rectangulaires, des formes ovales
c'est à dire qu'il y a différentes morphologies
des pièces,
des colliers.
Et donc on a on a fait des analyses avec l'accélérateur de particules du Louvre, AGLAE,
qui est dans les sous sols du Louvre,  et donc là on a trouvé que chaque gisement avait des caractéristiques chimiques
particulières qui nous permettait de déterminer
l'origine des objets en faisant des annales chimiques et par comparaison.
Et donc
on a pu mettre en évidence que dans la région de Carnac les objets
provenaient tous d'Espagne, qu'ils ne provenaient absolument pas d'à côté de Nantes, de Pannecé. A priori les derniers résultats montrent que
ils ne proviennent pas non plus de Gavà, de Barcelone mais plutôt
d'Ibérie. Alors au début les monuments les plus anciens,
c'est l'Andalousie, Encinasola, la province de Huelva
et,  bond, dès le cinquième millénaire et les ...
il y a une certaine rupture aux environs de 4000 avant jésus-christ où les
néolithiques allaient s'approvisionner
s'approvisionner en variscite
dans la région de Zamora, à
Palazuelo de las Cuevas."